Speaker 1: Okay. So there's like a wacky, almost
funny element to this story, and then there's
a very real scary, politically substantive
element to this story. We're going to start with a
video from. It's so hard to even say what this is.
I believe that this is a Christian church.
Okay. And this is a rant at a Christian church
about how the right, the religious right wants to
take control of the educational system and use the
educational system to indoctrinate students with a
conservative, right wing, reactionary, Christian,
Bible based worldview as they see it. This is
really scary. Now, what's the wacky part about
it? Well, I can't tell whether this is a Christian
church or an insane asylum. There's people
screaming. You'll notice that while the guy on the
microphone is ranting, you'll hear other voices.
And if you're watching, you'll see people in the
background talking over the guy. At one point,
it seems like the guy is speaking in tongues, I
think, although I'm not an expert in speaking in
tongues. And this is a movement where I can't
tell whether this is a church or an insane
asylum. Take a look at this. Now, Lord.
Speaker 4: According to your word,
we take authority over our education system. And,
Lord, we call for righteousness in our education
system. True in our education system.
Speaker 1: Justice in our education.
I think the woman over the guys
right shoulder just keeps saying,
that's right. That's right. That's right. That's
right. I don't. It seems almost like this is a.
It seems like the spirit has overtaken them.
Unidentified: We cast down that demonic role
of indoctrination in our education system.
Speaker 1: So anyway, now the guy's casting
a spell, I guess, to take
control of schools. And God.
Unidentified: We declare that there's no
education outside of the Word of the living
God. There's no true education outside of that.
Speaker 1: The other. Oh, whoa, whoa. Hold on. I
almost talked over the tongues. Hold on a second.
Speaker 4: Education outside of the frame,
I've said.
Speaker 1: All right, so
extremely dangerous view about education. We
want to take over education with Christianity.
But also they're speaking in tongues and screaming
and it seems like everybody should be medicated.
Bored of the living God. We declare.
Speaker 4: According to your word,
that all of our children.
Unidentified: Shall be disciples of the Lord
and great shall be the peace and undisturbed.
Speaker 4: Composure of our children.
So God, we call for righteousness in
every level of education and call.
Speaker 1: For the righteous. Does anybody know
why everybody's talking over this guy in the
background? It's a bizarre scene or intended.
Speaker 2: Righteous teacher,
righteous principles.
Speaker 4: Righteous righteousness. Now and then.
By righteousness. And the word of righteousness.
Unidentified: The demonic and the deception and
the evil that is calling the classroom.
Speaker 4: Would be bring
it out by the hand of God.
Speaker 2: Driven by the hand of God, driven.
Unidentified: Out now by the hand of God and
God. I thank you for young people who are taught.
Speaker 2: According to your Word.
Speaker 1: In Jesus. So I don't even really
understand what the hell is going on there. But
the really serious part is they want to take over
public education and now for a slightly just as
just as wrong but less obviously out of their mind
view on this. We go to a clip of Tony Perkins.
Tony Perkins, the well-known homophobic right
wing Christian activist that we've followed
for a long time on the show. He said, Well,
listen, we want young conservatives to go into
teaching in public schools so that we can put our
Christian worldview into public schools, despite
the fact that you're that's that's against the
law. There's supposed to be separation of church
and state. You're not supposed to be teaching
Christianity other than as a comparative
religious type class in public schools.
This is their plan. Listen to Tony Perkins.
Speaker 2: I don't think we should abandon
the public schools. I encourage young people
who want to go into the teaching profession
to see the public schools as a mission
field. We cannot abandon it. We need to
run for the school board. We need to be
teachers. We need to be administrators.
But we don't need to sacrifice our children.
Speaker 1: Understand what he means by the public.
Schools are a mission field. He's talking about
missionaries in the same way that missionaries
would go to, you know, over the years they would
go to Brazil and make first contact in the Amazon
and and try to convert people to Christianity.
He's saying, see the public schools as a mission
field where we go in and do the exact same thing.
Speaker 2: In that environment. So I am not
saying we abandon the public schools. We too
many kids are going to continue to go there.
But it shouldn't be our kids. We should
send our kids as teachers and instructors.
Speaker 1: Right. So what Tony
Perkins is saying is and think about
this is Dark Ages stuff. This is let's do the
following. Here's the idea. Our kids, we send to
Christian private schools where they get or we
do Christian homeschooling, which is remember,
the overwhelming majority of homeschooling
in the U.S. is Christian oriented. Think 75
close to 80% of it. Their kids, they do Christian
homeschooling or Christian private schools,
but then they still infect the
public schools with their ideology
by taking the kids who went to the Christian
private schools, having them go into teaching
and then send them into the public schools, also
to teach Christianity and to see it as a mission
field, as they say, to be missionaries in public
schools, which at least in theory, are supposed
to abide by separation of church and state. This
is really scary stuff. So like, listen, I get it.
The guy speaking in tongues, it's crazy where we
say Medicate everyone. Psych eval, 72 hour hold,
but they have money, at least some. They're
well-organized, relatively speaking. And
this is exactly what they they're telling us
what they're planning to do. And we know it's
what they're planning to do. And when you look
at the level of organization, I mean, look,
when that when the school mask and vaccine stuff
got going during COVID, as the vaccines came out,
that level of organization, it was a lot
of these same people who were showing up to
the school board meetings. They are organized,
there's no doubt about it. And so if we don't
take this threat seriously, they may be far more
successful than maybe we're willing to admit.